every single day what do I have to be
doing that hopefully in the long run
will mean I can say yeah 70% of my
business comes from referral I made it
on my to-do list my plan yeah you had
your candidate calls you had your client
work etc the first thing I did every
morning at 8:00 was repost a news
article about cyber security MH as
simple as that right it's force a habit
right even the professionals don't use
Instagram anymore they're stra LinkedIn
everyone's on the toilet in the morning
LinkedIn LinkedIn LinkedIn how do they
see Josh key on their on the thing and
they're liking it and sharing it if you
can go one better and start writing your
own articles and things and great but
more importantly every single morning
8:00 get something out there so create
your content and it just becomes part of
you it's a habit and it builds your own
personal brand espcially personal
marketing